hey youtubers it's charlie this is going
to be my aero brave and the bulb video
and just like the flash video last night
because there were so much crazy stuff
i'm going to make it a top 10 video
instead of just regular top five i've
also got previews for episode nine of
both shows so i'll play both of those
during this video whenever i get to
those moments so really the big takeaway
from the episode is when they said next
time meaning there's totally gonna be
more crossovers but careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet starting with top 10 moments number
10 amanda waller teaches oliver how to
torture people so just to address all
the torture stuff in the episode the
producer said this was an episode all
about the morality of being a hero arrow
versus the flash and the way they treat
justice the flashbacks just showed how
oliver got to the point where he is now
where he got to like that batman dark
justice place i felt kind of bad for him
it seems like no matter what he does he
can't win like he can't torture the
person in the flashback so the bombs go
off in the future he is able to torture
the person but they use it against him
so both cases he loses i really think it
ends up being a case-by-case basis kind
of thing yes torture can be effective
but it is a really dark thing and can
totally come back around lots of puns in
the episode to get you number nine queen
industries is now officially palmer tech
i flipped a little when i saw the sign
on top of the building it was such a
throwaway moment too they totally buried
the lead that's gonna come back in
episode nine that'll be more of an issue
in next week's episode we didn't see ray
palmer at all so they really didn't
address any of the palmer tech stuff it
was really all about bringing team flash
into the story in the most appropriately
hilarious way possible seriously i
totally love cisco and caitlyn number
eight team flash in the arrow cave we
don't call it that ever such a great
felicity reaction when she was the one
that did the same thing when roy walked
in and said what is this like the arrow
cave and felicity said yeah we totally
call it that it was just giving oliver's
line to her i love the way that they
trade lines like that felicity is like
the oliver of the situation just like
wanting them to take things seriously
team flashing the arrow cave was really
a comedy moment i mean there's a whole
lot of stuff going on but they said it
themselves later in the episode we don't
take things seriously like in starling
it's really dark and gritty in central
city they haven't got to that point yet
like they're still riding high on
superpowers so it just gives us a chance
to have some more fun inside the
aerocave just like cisco geeking out on
all the trick arrows and yes he did
tease that he's going to develop some
tech i mean oliver got the suit at the
end of the episode which i'll totally
talk about in a second that's not all he
was talking about like he was talking
about upgrading everything which will
totally happen like that will totally
come to pass that'll be where a lot of
the passive crossover between the shows
will happen in the future where
characters don't go on each other's
shows they'll be like oh we got this
gift from star labs we'll actually see
what that is in episode 9 and it'll have
something to do with solving the mystery
of sarah's killer like whatever the tech
that they give them it'll help them
solve the mystery another one of my
favorite moments from the episode hands
down one of my favorite jokes was
caitlyn asking about the salmon ladder
bar yeah i mean grant gustin had that
funny moment where he did it at super
speed it's him not realizing why the
girls like it so much like it's not that
oliver does a lot of them it's just that
he does them in a way that's very
appealing to the women on the show so
flash salmon ladders not as cool as
arrow salmon ladders number seven
captain boomerang vs argus so this is
like our introduction to captain
boomerang and he basically just hands
everyone's asses to them it's actually a
really awesome big action scene really
the advantage of using all those
boomerangs is that they can take the
corners it also answers what digger
hardness the character is doing he's
coming after lila because she tried to
scrub a mission meaning she tried to
kill the team that was on the mission so
they wouldn't be discovered i don't
really consider that an easter egg i
mean every suicide squad movie or story
we've ever seen has dealt with the issue
of amanda waller implanting explosive
devices in people's heads i did think it
was kind of strange that amanda waller
was in the flashbacks but wasn't in any
of the present day scenes but i think
they might have kept her out just to
keep things from getting too confusing
the captain boomerang character was
actually created by carmine infantino
they actually had a shout out where they
did a street sign that was named
infantino like a street intersection
they do that on air all the time where
street names are named after comic book
creators the reason they picked captain
boomerang for this crossover episode is
because he was a flash villain like he
was a member of the rogues so he fits in
both universes he was also a member of
the suicide squad in the comics arrows
doing suicide squad flash is doing the
rogues so it just matched up really
nicely number six the flash saves oliver
so barry gets his entrance into the
crossover just the same way oliver got a
really cool entrance into the flash side
of the crossover there was also the
funny like marilyn monroe tease moment
where he was running past thea on his
way there before the episode stephen
amell did this q a where he was asked to
do like two lies one truth about the
episode and turns out we learned it was
a lie now but when he was doing the q a
he said thea has the closest to a
marilyn monroe moment as you can do on
network television that's like where the
wind blows her dress up and shows her
underwear and yes that was the dj that
she was talking to like the douchebag dj
she was talking to on the phone about
the kiss number five flareo morality
explained so like i said the producer
said this was all about the morality of
being a superhero the morality of
justice treated in both universes the
arrow and the flash i liked cisco's
explanation you know that meta humans
were like answer maybe not god's answer
like dark matter wave answer to all the
crazy people like they've always been
crazy people and now meta humans are
around to deal with it a lot of
collateral damage down the road though
not all metahumans are going to be nice
as we will find out next week on the
flash a la man in the yellow suit diggle
and cisco is a pretty good team up too i
want to see more scenes with them
together diggle's kind of like the old
man of the episode i feel bad for him
because he's actually really young like
he's about the same age as oliver maybe
just a little bit older but he's like i
remember back in my day there were no
superpowers which isn't true actually we
know that's not true now number four
oliver's fight scene with captain
boomerang at the end so earlier in the
episode we had like that big captain
boomerang action scene where he's
fighting like a bunch of people but now
this is like the one-on-one fight which
is just as awesome actually i feel arrow
does these kinds of action scenes even
better like really intimate close-up
action scenes it's just more fun to
watch just because you're that much
closer to the action and once again
oliver is able to get the upper hand on
someone with superior technology it's
not so much about who has the best toys
or the best powers it's really about who
uses the situation to their advantage
the most and that's what oliver is the
best at i mean barry even said it to him
like since their team up since the
flashlight of the team up he's been
casing crime scenes before he engages
the criminals so oliver is still kind of
like the jedi master of the episode
despite being the one that has like the
least amount of crazy gadgets although
he does have some really awesome trick
arrows number three the rocky iii ending
while the episode was happening greg
berlanti one of the producers said to
watch out for a really awesome reference
to a movie that was the favorite of all
the producers that that includes andrew
kriesberg and mark guggenheim whenever i
saw them like run at each other all i
could think of was rocky iii but it
turns out he confirmed it it was rocky
iii fellairo bros forever they didn't
explain why it's their favorite movie i
mean i'm sure there's a number of
reasons there's a lot of like thematic
things that line up with apollo creed
and rocky training together just like
the flash and arrow most the time when
people talk about the movie it's it's
like in a comical way number two the
episode nine reish al ghul teaser they
dropped a couple teasers in the episode
so i'm just gonna go ahead and play it
right here
the citizens of styling will see what
the league of assassins is capable of
if you fight razakul
he'll kill you
this is a duel
with one of the most dangerous men that
has ever walked the earth you've taken
your last life
so essentially what's going on is this
is happening in modern day i know there
was a lot of confusion about that razal
ghoul gives oliver 48 hours to find
sarah's killer the episode is titled the
climb so presumably he has to climb this
mountain wherever this is to fight razor
ghoul for justice like he probably gives
him the option like i'll either take
down starling looking for this person or
you can fight me otherwise i can't think
of a lot of reasons for oliver to fight
razor ghoul in the snow and my number
one moment the man in the yellow suit
teaser so i'm just going to go ahead and
play this real quick too the witness
says all he saw was a blur
what did it look like like a man
that
this man sent my mother through the
heart this is my fight
so this is the episode where we finally
meet the reverse flash that's what
they're calling them the reverse flash i
mean there's a lot of different names
you could call them but as you can see
in this shot here harrison wells and
eddie thawne both looking at him so it's
neither one of them unless it's a future
version of one of them which i don't
think is the case just like there are
multiple flashes like there's bart allen
which we got a shout out to in the
episode there are multiple reverse
flashes this is just gonna be the first
one and we're not gonna find out his
identity like his face will be blurred
don't worry we can do tons of guessing
whenever that episode comes next week
let me know what was your favorite
moment from the episode and who do you
think the villain should be for their
next crossover like what about slade
wilson i actually just forgot to mention
it during my top 10 but they stuck
captain boomerang in the same argus
underground prison that slaves in the
funny thing about that is that both of
those actors like maneu bennett and the
actor that played captain boomerang
they're from spartacus so it's like a
bit of a mini reunion for them if
they're going to be in an episode in the
future slade wilson confirmed to be
coming back in episode 14 but it's also
possible that captain boomerang could
come back in that episode too if it's
not a flashback just something to get
really excited about also the new aero
suit there will be more upgrades like
cisco said that he found a fabricator in
starland city meaning that when he makes
upgrades like you'll see them on arrow
it's basically just a stronger version
of the suit that he can put more trick
arrows on like more gadgets i think ray
palmer is going to develop some tech for
him too like he'll get some palmer tech
added to that suit now that he has
capacity to carry more stuff on it all
in all i gave the episode a solid ape it
was a totally great crossover i know
crossovers can sometimes get a little
too weird i thought they did an amazing
job one of the things i think that they
did really well was not just completely
do the exact same thing they did on the
flash they changed the tone the arc was
different it was like a completely
different episode like you could watch
this episode without having watched the
flash episode i know there's always
questions about that like do i have to
watch the flash to understand what's
going on on arrow and vice versa my
favorite performance in the episode was
stephen amell just because he had to
carry the complete emotional through
line grant gustin did have to be
something of a foil emotionally for him
just with the morality this was all on
stephen amell and he even had to play
two different versions of oliver it's
always fun to listen to his voice like
the way he inflects his voice when he's
young oliver versus the present day
oliver who has like the really dark
batman voice i totally love their gritty
dark captain boomerang whenever you see
him in the comics or you see him like in
the cartoons he tends to be a little
more comical like a little sillier so i
am happy to see them try something a
little bit different this is more like a
christopher nolan captain boomerang just
think about that wouldn't that be crazy
i know the show always tries to be
really realistic with the way it
portrays the crazy stuff but mark
guggenheim actually just said that
because of this crossover episode he's
kind of opened his mind to doing
superpowers on arrow so it is possible
we could see meta humans on arrow like
he changed his mind literally in the
last couple of weeks on that it's just
that before that he said it was a hard
and fast rule no superpowers on arrow
with the exception of like barry allen
one of my favorite easter eggs in the
episode though was when quentin lance
called barry bart allen who's obviously
we know is kid flash it's just a great
easter egg and a great call out to a
future character that we might see on
the flash for real like we'll see wally
west before we see bart allen but it's
totally possible yes they have confirmed
they are doing wally west not anytime
soon though like it's gonna take a while
to get there i imagine in this
continuity that they've set up he'll end
up being like a cousin of irises all in
all amazing episode don't forget though
next week episode 9 of both shows so be
sure to subscribe to get my videos from
that i will do bonus videos in the off
season i think arrows should be coming
back on the 14th of january and the
flash will probably just come back at
the exact same time too so it'll be off
the air for like five weeks which isn't
that big a deal real quick reminder if
you're on your mobile phone or on your
tablet there's new links up here that
you can click on it's the same as the
links over here but click here for my
flash versus arrow video and click here
for all my other arrow bonus videos
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high five i will see you guys
tomorrow
you